talk about the senate now controlled by
democrats they confirmed the first of
president biden's cabinet nominees last
night avril haynes will be the new
director of national intelligence
the first woman ever appointed to that
position nicole killian is on capitol
hill for us where the nominee for
transportation secretary will have his
confirmation hearings this morning
that's pete buttige
nicole what do we expect to hear well
tony p but a judge will
vow to work with congress on issues like
safety and
infrastructure but the pressure is on to
quickly confirm the president's nominees
now the democrats have the advantage
a changing of the guard in the u.s
senate so help you
god thank you congratulations
democrats took back the majority as vice
president kamala harris swore in georgia
senators rafael warnock and john assaf
and her own replacement the chair lays
before the senate two certificates of
election
for the state of georgia and a
certificate of appointment to fill the
vacancy
created by the resignation of former
senator kamala d harris of california
yeah that was very weird okay with both
chambers and the white house
and now in democrats control party
leaders have not
indicated when an impeachment trial for
former president trump could begin
instead appealing for unity the
democratic majority will strive
to make this important work bipartisan
our country deserves for both sides both
parties
to find common ground but the
president's policy agenda
may not be as widely embraced from a new
immigration package to a covid relief
plan
republican senator mitt romney is among
those balking at the 1.9
trillion dollar price tag to deliver new
aid to struggling americans
we just passed a a program with over 900
billion dollars in it
i'm not looking for a new program in the
immediate future
lawmakers are also at odds over whether
to grant a waiver to defense nominee
lloyd austin
the retired general needs the exemption
since he's only been out of the military
for a few years the house is trying to
fast track
a vote on it today to expedite his
confirmation but
some are opposed even though these types
of waivers have been
granted before gail all right nicole
thank you very much